probably an important step to defend
your title this was a difficult match it
felt like nothing can separate you to
until the last game take us through this
last final match yeah you know I had
this idea or we had this idea with my
second in the second rapid game already
in classical and
we just weren't sure
if it's like worth it for a classical
game but now I'm starting to regret
because of course I mean the match was
very good overall but
um but it feels like maybe it was even
worth it for a classical game and which
one is the idea this Knight to D2 well
he had played C5 once uh Against One
Forest like in this position no no in
the game like after Queen C2 C5 he had
played before Against One Forest
I think you can see it down there yep
and Castle is a very rare move
there was a game of Friedman which went
exactly like the game cd49 C4 Knight C6
Rook D1
and the thing is Rook 96 is a very
serious mistake yeah and it's one of
those rare moments when a very natural
move is a very serious mistake black
needs to play D3 here
to equalize yeah and it's still a tough
fight so it's not like
uh I was I wasn't too concerned about
this because I thought I'll still be
able to play a game with chances and the
other way that black can play is to take
on D2 instead of DC4 which was a bit
unusual and not
it also kind of equalizes but it's not
easy for black to play like this and we
were actually shocked that after D1
Queen E7 A3 the computer gives you a
decisive Advantage did you know that uh
I just knew how to Rook D1 on better I
didn't I didn't remember the move Queen
E7
so it didn't worry me because like when
he was thinking I was also thinking
Queen E7 is a semi-natural move to try
to get E5
but after A3 it looked really dangerous
um I didn't know it was this bad but
yeah I had a feeling I have a very nice
position and then Rook be it as a
blunder
but anyway it looks very unpleasant
especially with the time situation
absolutely a big matchup big victory for
you tomorrow you will be facing Wesley
so a very difficult opponent very
difficult opponent to beat in any time
control how do you feel about that
particular matchup yeah it's it's a very
tough match of course Wesley is really
proficient in every time control so if
it goes from classical to rabbit or to
Blitz it's not like it ever gets any
easier and we've we played a lot uh you
know I think we have a relatively
balanced score overall but we've played
uh like I don't know how many years how
many games we've played so so definitely
we have a lot of experience against each
other I think it will be will be a very
tough match and hopefully
um hopefully I'll be in good shape guys
any questions uh just uh it's not a
hilarious moment or anything like that
um uh Fabi but there was this moment
where a bishop to D2 I've been I've been
doing my best to educate uh the
commentators about grabbing pawns you
perhaps saw the move Bishop D2 but stop
yourself after the move A5 but you did
have this moment of A5 I think it's A5
which is actually really good for you
uh it you played Rook D1 and went on to
to win nicely did you see anything like
this or you just stopped yourself after
no after A5 I considered let's say Rook
C1 E5 and Rook H4 which is pretty
typical to put the Rook on H4 in some
positions I considered things like that
and I takes A5 didn't
even cross my mind
um if you told me there's a way to win a
pawn probably I would
would notice this but
um I think this is one of those cases
where it's good to see a little bit less
because I mean Rook D1 and Bishop D2
ended up being much more
um much cleaner I guess as it turned out
than than this might be and rather than
calculate all this stuff and
take up the courage to to play it you
know I think it's easier to just play
Rook D1 Fair uh good luck in uh your
next uh match coming up tomorrow thank
you good luck wow